[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE WARDEN: So thanks
so much, Raziel.
And I'm real excited to be here
to talk about a new project
that I think is pretty cool.
So TensorFlow Lite
for microcontrollers--
what's that all about?
So this all comes back to when
I actually first joined Google
back in 2014.
And as you can imagine,
there were a whole bunch
of internal projects
that I didn't actually
know about, as a member
of the public, that
sort of blew my mind.
But one in particular
came about when I actually
spoke to Raziel for the
first time, and he explained.
And he was on the speech
team at the time working
with Alex, who you just saw.
And he explained that they
use neural network models
of only 13 kilobytes in size.
At that time I only really had
experience with image networks.
And the very smallest
of them was still
like multiple megabytes.
So this idea of having
a 13-kilobyte model
was just amazing for me.
And what amazed me
even more was when
he told me why these
models had to be so small.
They needed to run them on these
DSPs and other embedded chips
in smartphones.
So Android could listen out for
wake words, like "Hey, Google,"
while the main CPU was powered
off to save the battery.
These microcontrollers
often only
had tens of kilobytes of
RAM and flash storage.
So they simply couldn't
fit anything larger.
They also couldn't rely
on cloud connectivity
because the amount of power that
would have been drained just
keeping a radio connection
alive to send data over
would have just
been prohibitive.
So that really struck
me, that conversation
and the continued work that
we did with the speech team,
because they had
so much experience
doing all sorts of different
approaches with speech.
They'd spent a lot of time and
a lot of energy experimenting.
And even within the
tough constraints
of these embedded
devices, neural networks
were better than any of the
traditional methods they used.
So I was left
wondering if they'd
be really useful for other
embedded sensor applications
as well.
And it left me really wanting
to see if we could actually
build support for these kind of
devices into TensorFlow itself,
so that more people could
actually get access.
At the time, only people
in the speech community
really knew about the
groundbreaking work that
was being done,
so I really wanted
to share it a lot more widely.
So [LAUGHS] today, I'm
pleased to announce
that we are releasing the
first experimental support
for embedded platforms
in TensorFlow Lite.
And to show you
what I mean, here
is a demonstration board that
I actually have in my pocket.
And this is a prototype
of a development
board built by SparkFun.
And it has a Cortex-M4 processor
with 384 kilobytes of RAM
and a whole megabyte
of flash storage.
And it was built by Ambiq
to be extremely low power,
drawing less than one
milliwatt in a lot of cases.
So it's able to run on a
single coin battery like this
for many days, potentially.
And I'm actually going to
take my life in my hands
now by trying a live demo.
[LAUGHS] So let us see
if this is actually--
it's going to be
extremely hard to see,
unless we dim the lights.
There we go.
So what I'm going
to be doing here
is, by saying a particular word,
and see if it actually lights
up the little yellow light.
You can see the
blue LED flashing.
That's just telling me that
it's running [INAUDIBLE]..
So if I try saying, yes.
Yes.
[LAUGHS] Yes.
[LAUGHS] I knew I was taking
my life into my hands here.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
There we go.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to quickly move
that out of the spotlight.
[LAUGHS] So as you can see,
it's still far from perfect.
[LAUGHS] But it
is managing to do
a job of recognizing
when I say the word,
and not lighting up when
there's unrelated conversations.
So why is this useful?
Well first, this is
running entirely locally
on the embedded chip.
So we don't need to have
any internet connection.
So it's a good, useful first
component of a voice interface
system.
And the model itself
isn't quite 13 kilobytes,
but it is down to 20 kilobytes.
So it only takes up 20
kilobytes of flash storage
on this device.
And the footprint of
the TensorFlow Lite
code for microcontrollers is
only another 25 kilobytes.
And it only needs about
30 kilobytes of RAM
available to operate.
So it's within the
capabilities of a lot
of different embedded devices.
Secondly, this is
all open source.
So you can actually
grab the code yourself
and build it yourself.
And you can modify it.
I'm showing you here on
this particular platform,
but it actually works
on a whole bunch
of different embedded chips.
And we really want to
see lots more supported,
so we're keen to work
with the community
on collaborating to get
more devices supported.
You can also train
your own model.
Just something that recognizes
yes isn't all that useful.
But the key thing is that
this comes with a [INAUDIBLE]
that you can use to actually
train your own models.
And it also comes
with a data set
of 100,000 utterances
of about 20 common words
that you use as
your training set.
And that first link there,
the aiyprojects one,
if you could actually
go to that link
and contribute your voice
to the open data set,
it should actually
increase the size
and the quality of the data
set that we can actually
make available.
So that would be awesome.
And you can actually
use the same approach
to do a lot of different
audio recognition
to recognize different
kinds of sounds,
and even start to use it for
similar signal processing
problems, like things like
predictive maintenance.
So how can you try
this out for yourself?
If you're in the audience
here, at the end of today,
you will find that
you get a gift box.
And you actually have
one of these in there.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
And all you should need to
do is remove the little tab
between the battery, and it
should automatically boot up,
pre-flashed, with
this yes example.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can try it
out for yourself,
and let me know how it goes.
Just say yes to
TensorFlow Lite is the--
[LAUGHTER]
And we also include
all the cables,
SO you should be able
to just program it
yourself through
the serial port.
Now these are the first
700 boards ever built,
so there is a wiring issue.
So it will drain the battery.
It won't last.
It would last more
like hours than days.
But that will actually,
knock on wood,
be fixed in the final
product that's shipping.
And you should be
able to develop
with these in the
exact same way that you
will with the final
shipping product.
And if you're
watching at home, you
can pre-order one of
these form SmartFun
right now for, I
think, it's $15.
And you'll also find lots
of other instructions
for other platforms
in the documentation.
So we are trying
to support as many
of the modern microcontrollers
that are out there that people
are using as possible.
And we welcome
collaboration with everybody
across the community to help
unlock all of the creativity
that I know is out there.
And I'm really
hoping that I'm going
to be spending a lot of my
time over the next few months
reviewing pull requests.
And finally, this is my
first hardware project,
so I needed a lot of
help from a lot of people
to actually help bring
this prototype together,
including the TF Lite team,
especially Raziel, Rocky, Dan,
Tim, and Andy.
Alister, Nathan, Owen, and Jim
at SparkFun were lifesavers.
We literally got these in
our hands middle of the day
yesterday.
[LAUGHTER]
So the fact that they
managed to pull it together
is a massive tribute.
And also Scott, Steve,
Arpit, and Andre
at Ambiq, who actually designed
this process and helped us
get the software going.
And actually a lot of people
at Arm as well, including a big
shout out to Neil and Zach.
So this is still a
very early experiment,
but I really can't wait to see
what people build with this.
And one final note.
I will be around
to talk about MCUs
with anybody who's interested
at the breakout session on day
two.
So I'm really looking forward
to chatting to everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAZIEL ALVAREZ: Thanks, Pete.
We really hope
that you try this.
I mean, it's the early stages,
but you see a huge effort
just to make this happen.
We think that it will be
really impactful for everybody.
Now before we go again--
and I promise this is the
last thing you hear from me--
I want to welcome
June, who's going
to talk about how, by using
TensorFlow Lite with the Edge
TPU Delegate are able to train
these teachable machines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JUNE TATE-GANS: Thanks, Raziel.
Hi.
My name is June Tate-Gans.
I'm actually one of the lead
software engineers inside
of Google's new Coral Group.
And I've been asked to
give a talk about the Edge
TPU-based teachable
machine demo.
So first, I should
tell you what Coral is.
Coral is a platform for products
with on-device machine learning
using TensorFlow and TF Lite.
Our first two products are
a single-board computer
and a USB stick.
So what is the Edge TPU?
It's a Google-designed ASIC that
accelerates inference directly
on the device that
it's embedded in.
It's very fast.
It localizes data to the
edge, rather than the cloud.
It doesn't require a
network connection to run.
And this allows for a whole
new range of applications
of machine learning.
So the first product we
built is the Coral Dev Board.
This is a single-board
computer with a removable SOM.
It runs Linux and Android.
And the SOM itself
has a gigabyte
of RAM, a quad-core A53
SoC, Wi-Fi and Bluetooth,
and of course the Edge TPU.
And the second is our
Coral accelerator board.
Now, this board is just
the Edge TPU connected
via USB-C to whatever
development system
you need, be it a Raspberry
Pi, or a Linux workstation.
Now, this teachable
machine shows off
a form of edge training.
Now traditionally, there's
three ways to do edge training.
There's k-nearest neighbors,
weight imprinting,
and last layer retraining.
But for this demo,
we're actually
using the k-nearest
neighbors approach.
So in this animated GIF, you
can see that the TPU enables
very high classification rates.
The frame rate you
see here is actually
the rate at which the
TPU is classifying
the images that I'm showing it.
In this case, you can
see that we're getting
about 30 frames per second.
It's essentially
real-time classification.
And with that, I actually have
one of our teachable machine
demos here.
So if we can turn this on.
There we go.
OK.
So on this board, we have our
Edge TPU development board
assembled with a camera
and a series of buttons.
And each button corresponds
with class and lights
up when the model identifies
an object from the camera.
First, we have to plug this in.
Now every time I take
a picture by pressing
one of these buttons, it
associates that picture
with that particular class.
And because it's running
inference on the Edge TPU,
it lights up immediately.
So once it's finished booting,
the first thing I have to do
is train it on the background.
So I'll press this blue
button, and you can
see it immediately turns on.
This is because, again, it's
doing inference in real time.
Now, if I train one of the
other buttons using something
like a tangerine,
press it a few times.
OK, so now you can see it can
classify between this tangerine
and the background.
And further, I can even
grab other objects,
such as this TF Light sticker--
it looks very similar, right?
It's the same color.
Let's see.
What was in the class I used?
Yellow, OK.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
So now, even though
it's a similar color,
IT can still discern
the TensorFlow Lite logo
from the tangerine.
Oh, sorry.
Tangerine, there we go.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So you can imagine in a
manufacturing context,
your operators, with
no knowledge of machine
learning or training
in machine learning,
can adapt your system
easily and quickly
using this exact technique.
So that's about it for the demo.
But before I go, I
should grab the clicker,
and also I should say, we're
also giving away some Edge TPU
accelerators.
For those of you
here today, we'll
have one available
for you as well.
And for those of you
on the Livestream,
you can purchase one at
coral.withgoogle.com.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]